[Music]
i did some research how much do you
think if you're obama and oprah i would
put them in similar categories maybe
obama a little bit above in terms of
influence but not like terribly above
how much do you think and i didn't ask
them i just researched it and i like try
to find contracts how much do you think
obama charges
i would guess something between
i would have guessed 250 to 350k that's
my guess for like a speaking engagement
but honestly it could be more it could
be like double that dude so i think it's
i heard rumors it's in like the one two
one point two million range
and that makes way wow obama is not
going to get out of bed for less than a
million and i hear oprah is around the 1
million no small boy stuff for obama too
no definitely not and so here's why so
i've heard like rumors and i talked to
people that have had them before and
that's kind of how i came with that
number but let me give you some insider
numbers so i only had one paid speaker
ever at hustlecon so at halsacon
collectively we probably had
200 or 300 speakers over a couple years
a handful of years
casey neistat was the only speaker that
we had who we paid and i was supposed to
you're not supposed to talk about how
much you pay him but like this was like
years ago so i can do it this was i
think at the height of his popularity
i only paid him 25 000
plus
a private flight from la to san francis
san francisco for six thousand dollars
or from san francisco to la i forget but
one way it was only six grand plus 25
thousand dollars that's nothing right
25 brand cheap compared to what because
he was at the peak of his powers at that
time too right it's not like yeah yeah
for sure he was like not like some
c-list you know person who used to be
famous it's like no guys he's not that
was a big deal then he's a big deal now
too so i tried to get gary vaynerchuk to
come speak at an event once and he
offered uh his asking price was a
hundred thousand dollars or i think he
said that you would have to buy a
hundred thousand dollars worth of books
and that somehow like pushes him up the
charts or
something like that and uh so gary
vaynerchuk was 100 grand um and i got to
speak i i spoke somewhat recently and i
asked i got paid 25 to 20 20 to 25
thousand dollars or maybe it's 20 grand
plus flights and then i think that we
had uh ashton kutcher spoke at an event
that i was at and the uh
the organizers like kind of like implied
like they paid them around 150 grand
so just just insider
stories
this has always been the playbook like i
met a guy once who was writing a book
and i was like nice like you know what's
your goals for the book and like he was
kind of answering me but i got the sense
like i feel like you know you ever hear
a story and you're like i feel like
you're leaving out the one important
detail that makes all of this make sense
like you're not
saying the wrong thing but i feel like
you're just not saying whatever the
right thing is
and sure enough like 20 minutes and he's
like
yeah basically you write books so that
you can get paid speaking gigs like it
doesn't matter who reads your book or
how you just need to be a guy who writes
a book and then you like do a thing you
like pay a certain amount to get like up
in the chart so you could say new york
times best seller or like
you know amazon best seller
and um and then that just increases your
paid speaking rate
by like 15k
and then that's like you know how you
make your money back for this whole like
book process
and i was like oh okay that makes way
more sense like now i understand and i
was like so this paid speaking gig like
how does this work and he kind of broke
it down for me kind of step by step
and i remember being intrigued but also
you know the cost of like
you know basically like the idea of like
oh yeah what you do is you fly around
like you basically have to go you're
never home you're flying around all the
time so he was at that point trying to
figure out all right
the next step after this you know and
and i sort of started thinking about
okay what is the move straight to the
end version of this and i was like oh
okay i think i know what i would do it's
like i would do a this is how like i was
thinking about the podcast at this time
like i was thinking about creating one i
was like i think i would do a podcast
that i could just record right here
whenever i want maybe in batches
and as long as the conversation's fun i
don't think i would care about making
any money off that
and i feel like if i could do that i
could get like
you know what if like a million people
were fans of the podcast i feel like
that would just jump me where all these
guys are trying to go or they're like
ultimately i think what a lot of people
want is like
they
have a topic that they're really curious
about that they like to research they
like to do experiments in and they're
just trying to figure out a way to get
paid to be professionally curious about
that thing i think that's like the
generous version of like how to think
about this there's like the skeptical
version of which is just like oh dude
you're just like some motivational
speaker like sort of scammy guru guy who
wants to go around and blah blah blah
but i think the re the earnest people i
think they just want to be
professionally curious it's like how do
i get to spend 90 of my time just like
digging in on this topic i'm a nerd
about and then like somehow translate
the other 10 of my time into enough
money to fund me to do that in a in a
cool way um and so i think that you know
that's how i think about this stuff
what i've been doing for speaking is i
actually haven't asked to be paid lately
but i do tell them i need two
first-class flights
um and i want you to pay entirely for
the hotel for a week and i will only say
yes if it's so my wife and i basically
so we can go to
a cool place so i only say yes but let
me tell you something interesting so
robert de niro he uh so the wall street
journal did this thing where meech our
friend ramitz shared it so listen to
robert so here's what robert de nil got
paid so he did a movie called savage
salvation in september 2020 he got paid
11 million dollars so he was going to be
there for eight days
he asked for a round trip private air
transportation on a gulf stream five is
that or six i don't know how roman
numerals work but a golf stream jet
he uh got to keep all of the costumes
wigs and prosthetics all the stuff that
he wore on this on the plane or all the
stuff he wore in the movie he got to
keep all of it he wanted an additional
fee for his uh
personal trainer he had to come and be
flown there and he had to be put up at
the ritz carlton
in addition to the the ten days that he
had or the eight days he had to be there
for production he wanted a seven day va
all expenses paid vacation to the ritz
carlton followed by a vacation in puerto
rico where you also had to pay for his
jet and i had to take his whole family
uh to and from uh and then finally he
wanted one round trip jet fra
one round-trip private flight jet
between new york and ella day in la for
a five-day stay anytime within 12 months
those are all of his ass in his contract
for all for eight days of work that's
not bad
[Music]
you